sehr geehrte damen und herren liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen ich wünsche
ihnen einen schönen guten morgen die
sitzung ist eröffnet
ich rufe auf
die tagesordnungspunkte guten morgen
tagesordnungspunkte 19a und 19
erste beratung des von den fraktionen
spd bündnis 90/die grünen und fdp
eingebrachten entwurfs eines
steuerentlastungsgesetzes
2022 sowie beratung des antrags der
fraktion der cdu/csu mit dem titel mut
zu wesentlichen steuerlichen
hilfsmaßnahmen
für die aussprache
wurde eine dauer von 68 minuten
beschlossen
ich eröffne die aussprache
und das wort hat der bundesminister
christian lindner
auch präsidentin guten morgen meine
damen und herren liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen wladimir putin führt seinen
schrecklichen verbrecherischen krieg
gegen die ukraine gegen unsere werte von
freiheit und selbstbestimmung und wir
wissen erscheinen nicht einmal davor
zurück brutalste gewalt anzuwenden und
grundlegende zivilisatorische werte zu
vernichten das kann nicht ohne reaktion
bleiben
das hat aber auch wirtschaftliche
konsequenzen für uns und das gilt umso
mehr vor dem hintergrund der gerade in
verschärfung begriffenen neuen
sanktionen die wachstumsaussichten
trüben sich bereits ein der
sachverständigenrat geht davon aus dass
unsere wirtschaft nunmehr nur noch um
1,8 prozent in diesem jahr wachsen wird
zudem sieht er eine inflationsrate von
6,1 prozent gleichzeitig hat sich der
arbeitsmarkt in deutschland im märz
allerdings trotz des kriegs in der
ukraine weiter erholt angesichts also
einer von hoher unsicherheit geprägten
lage ist es ein gebot ökonomischer und
politischer vernunft das wachstum in
deutschland zu stärken
inflationsrisiken entgegenzutreten und
härten abzufedern
anders als während der korona pandemie
geht es jetzt aber um so mehr um
entschlossenes handeln das aber gezielt
erfolgt denn wir gehen sorgsam mit dem
geld der bürgerinnen und bürger
und deshalb ist eine unserer
wesentlichen maßnahmen dieses
steuerentlastungsgesetz
wir sichern
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen wir
sichern den bürgerinnen und bürgern mehr
geld im portemonnaie und wir sichern den
betrieben liquidität damit stützen wir
langfristig die zuversicht in eine gute
wirtschaftliche entwicklung und ich sage
es klar es ist eine absicht auch der
koalition die bei den menschen ankommen
die gefühlte inflation zu dämpfen denn
das ist ein beitrag gefährliche lohn
preis spiralen zu verhindern
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen später
mutige tat werden wir mit dem vierten
quartal hilfe gesetz noch weitere
erleichterungen auf den weg bringen und
heute mittag werde ich mit robert habeck
öffentlich machen welche zusätzlichen
unternehmenshilfen die bundesregierung
auf den weg bringt nichts tun ist in
dieser lage keine option
mit den entwurf des
steuerentlastungsgesetzes
2022 den wir jetzt diskutieren geht es
um die bürgerinnen und bürger direkt und
unmittelbar wir wollen sich schnell und
unbürokratisch entlasten wir helfen vor
allem den haushalten die in besonderer
weise von herzen getroffen sind aber wir
nehmen auch die sorgen der breiten mitte
war zur ehrlichkeit wird aber eines dazu
die mittel des staates sind endlich darf
sich jetzt in dieser situation auch
nicht fiskalisch erschöpfen als
staatliche verantwortungsgemeinschaft
müssen wir uns insbesondere an die am
stärksten
betroffenen wenden und wir müssen
wirtschaftliche struktur brüche
verhindern einen allgemeinen wohlstands
verlust unseres landes infolge von
steigenden preisen für importe könnte
der staat aber nicht dauerhaft
ausgleichen auch das was wir jetzt hier
vorgelegt haben entbindet uns nicht von
einer grundlegenden einer neu grund
gründung der quellen unseres wohlstands
durch marktwirtschaftliche programme
durch öffentliche investitionen und vor
allem durch viele gemeinsame arbeit
ich jede bereits punkte hervor erstens
neben den grundfreibetrag an ein
außergewöhnlicher schritt normalerweise
findet unterjährig ja keine anpassung
stadt wir gehen diesen schritt weil wir
eine notwendigkeit einer schnellen
entlastung sehen und weil die
vorgängerregierung die wirtschaftliche
entwicklung und insbesondere die
inflation dieses jahres unterschätzt hat
deshalb werden wir jetzt alle
einkommensteuerpflichtigen entlasten
durch den höheren grundfreibetrag und
zweitens werden wir rückwirkend zum
ersten januar den arbeitnehmer
pauschbetrag auf 1200 euro anheben der
ist seit elf jahren nicht angefasst
worden und jetzt wird er um 20 prozent
erhöht das ist ein starkes signal und
ich füge hinzu diese maßnahmen wirken
auf dauer sie bleiben und mit der
vorlage des progression berichtes werden
wir auch vorschläge für die
weiterentwicklung 20 23 und 24 machen es
darf nicht dazu kommen dass die
tarifentwicklung jetzt bei den
beschäftigten im zuge der lohnrunde dass
die obwohl sie nur die kaufkraft
ausgleicht am ende zu einer stärkeren
steuerlichen belastung führt das wären
in dieser krise automatische
steuererhöhungen die wir abwenden müssen
und drittens kocht noch ein mobilitäts
prämie und die vorgezogene anhebung der
entfernungspauschale auf 38 cent 4,5
milliarden euro ist dieses paket alle
maßnahmen insgesamt die die
bundesregierung im deutschen bundestag
vorlegt summieren sich auf mehr als 16
milliarden euro in der vollen
jahreswirkung war einer familie mit zwei
erwerbstätigen ergibt sich dadurch eine
entlastung von 500 euro im jahr wir
handeln in dieser krise und tun das was
notwendig ist und kaum jemand hätte der
ampel zugetraut dass eine der ersten
maßnahmen ein steuerentlastungsgesetz
ist dass mehr netto vom brutto bringt
[Applaus]
nächster redner für die cdu csu fraktion
ist der kollege fritz künstler
bislang hatte finanzausschuss liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen meine damen und
herren und zuhörer wir sind froh dass
wir heute über ein
steuerentlastungsgesetz debattieren
können die notwendigkeit hat der
bundesfinanzminister ja auch eben
dargestellt aber der
bundesfinanzminister eine ein punkt
würde ich sie doch korrigieren wollen
sie haben gerade davon gesprochen es
gebe eine gefühlte inflation also ich
glaube dann sie mit den menschen auf der
straße sprechen das ist keine gefühlte
inflation sondern die inflation ist bei
den menschen angekommen und deshalb
müssen wir reagieren
wir hatten eine inflation von 4,9
prozent im januar 5,1 prozent im februar
und 7,3 prozent im märz das ifo institut
geht davon aus dass wir vier fünf und
sechs prozent inflationsrate in diesem
jahr liegen werden das ist die höchste
inflation seit 40 jahren darum da ist es
die verdammte pflicht der regierung hier
zu reagieren dann müssen sie nicht
ständig selber loben das eine
selbstverständlichkeit
also von daher sind wir grundsätzlich
froh dass es heute auf der tagesordnung
steht dass sie einen entwurf gemacht
haben sie blasen denen jetzt hier ein
bisschen rhetorisch auf denn wenn wir
uns das wirklich angucken ist es etwas
wenig was da passiert ist und wir sind
auch überrascht herr minister am 16
februar haben sie an dieser stelle bei
der befragung der bundesregierung gesagt
man könne freibeträge tarife nicht
unterjährig anpassen weil das zu viel
aufwand bedeuten würde für die
finanzverwaltung jetzt machen sie das
ist auch gut so sie haben anscheinend an
erkenntnisgewinn das ist ja für minister
gut dass er auch erkenntnisse aufnimmt
denn wir haben damals schon gesagt
natürlich können wir den tarif anpassen
im laufenden jahr natürlich können wir
den grundfreibetrag anpassen von da ist
es gut dass wir jetzt auf dem weg sind
aber es ist noch zu wenig meine damen
und herren
denn das thema kalte progression haben
sie nach wie vor nicht aufgegriffen sie
erhöhen den grundfreibetrag wo man sich
die frage stellen kann um 363 euro auf
1010 1347 euro und laut
gesetzesbegründung das kann man auch
nachlesen unterstellen sie dabei eine
inflation für das jahr 2022 von drei
prozent diejenigen geschildert habe
legen wir bei fünf bis sechs prozent von
daher ist die maßnahme an sich richtig
aber nicht ausreichend meine damen und
herren von daher müssen sie dann noch
mal eine schippe drauflegen und
sie selber waren es ja als noch als sie
noch in der opposition waren immer
gesagt haben der staat darf nicht von
den heimlichen steuererhöhungen
profitieren und jetzt haben sie die
möglichkeit darauf zu reagieren und
meine bitte herr mit
bundesfinanzminister ist mit der ampel
koalition auch da die haben jetzt die
möglichkeit in der ampelkoalition darauf
zu reagieren und das wäre glaube ich gut
und von daher sollten sie dann auch
überlegen ob sie den progression bericht
nicht vorziehen darüber haben wir an der
befragung umfassend diskutiert damit wir
die kalte progression tatsächlich
absenken können dass wir die
tarifeckwerte anpassen können dass wir
das kindergeld anpassen können den
kinderfreibetrag ankündigen denn sie
anpassen können sind sie haben hier
lediglich eine maßnahme rausgesucht und
in dem zusammenhang wäre es glaube ich
auch gut wenn wir gemeinsam nicht in
diesem gesetz alle drei andere
koalitionäre haben das in ihrem
wahlprogramm drin stehen gehabt wir auch
über den einkommensteuertarif mal zu
diskutieren den mittelstandsbauch
abzubauen also daraus eine gemeinsame
kraftanstrengung zu machen weil das sehr
teuer sein wird dass wir gemeinsam dafür
eine lösung finden dass wir uns so leid
tatsächliche entlastung der mittleren
und höheren einkommen ihren deutschland
kommen können wir als union sind dabei
gerne mit vorschlägen und in der
diskussion und tragen das dann auch
gerne mit meine damen und herren dann
haben sie herausgestellt dass der
arbeitnehmerpauschbetrag um 20 prozent
auf 1200 euro erhöht wird
das kann man begrüßen insbesondere wenn
man dadurch einen vorteil hat sie haben
aber in ihrer rede auch ausgeführt der
bundesfinanzminister dass sie nur
zielgerichtete maßnahmen
angehen wollen die einfache erhöhung des
pauschbetrages ist keine zielgerichtete
maßnahmen der bundesverband der
lohnsteuerhilfevereine hat in seiner
stellungnahme geschrieben von der
anhebung profitieren jedoch
hauptsächlich arbeitnehmer die überhaupt
keine oder nur geringe beruflich
veranlasste aufwendungen haben sowie
diejenigen deren aufwendung vom
arbeitgeber erstattet werden dafür geben
sie eine million eine milliarde aus ohne
dass es zielgerichtet ist es gibt andere
dinge die wir wichtiger machen wir sind
die zielgerichtet gemacht werden könnten
von daher ist das glaube ich auch ein
eher eine werbeveranstaltung bei dem
werbungskostenpauschbetrag die sie hier
durch für meine damen und herren und
damen zur entfernungspauschale
da sage ich selbstkritisch auch wir
haben von den 38 cent gesprochen glaube
ich auch in einer situation als noch
nicht unbedingt erkennbar war wie die
spritpreise steigen das ist eine da ist
wo entfernungskilometer sind es 13 das
ist fünf gefahrenen kilometer 1,5 cent
wenn ich mir angucke dass ein
durchschnittliches wenn ich jetzt in
diesel nehme wenn man die noch fahren
darf haben sie sieben liter verbrauch
auf 100 kilometer wenn sie 80 cent
steigerung unterstellen dann sind sie
pro gefahrenen kilometer 1 bei einer
zusätzlichen belastung die er bei 5 bis
6 cent liegt und sie erhöhen hier um
drei cent es geht nur um ein
werbungskostenabzug das ist zu weniger
minister hier müssen wir noch gemeinsam
eine schippe drauflegen damit wir
tatsächlich zu einer entlastung kommen
und ein genereller fehler
ist an dem wir auch mitgewirkt haben ich
finde das kann man auch ich sagen dass
wir zwei klassen gesellschaft bei den
pendlern haben ich glaube es ist nicht
mehr zu rechtfertigen dass wir die
erhöhten der entfernungspauschale haben
ab dem 21 kilometer jeder kilometer muss
die höhere entfernungspauschale haben
das sollten wir in diesem
gesetzgebungsvorhaben vielleicht auch
noch mal angehen
sehr geehrte kolleginnen und kollegen
viel gebe es noch zu sagen ich hätte
auch gerne was zu unserem antrag gesagt
dem wir parallel eingebracht haben aber
wir haben ja heute noch die gelegenheit
zum corona steuer hilfe gesetz diese
debatte zu führen oder kollege dörr wenn
sie so eine angriffsfläche bieten dann
muss ich mich erst mal an ihm abarbeiten
bevor ich unseren guten antrag
darstellen aber sie haben ja die
möglichkeit im rahmen der
gesetzesberatung diesen antrag weiter zu
verbessern in dem gesetzentwurf weiter
zu verbessern wir als union als
konstruktive opposition stehen in gerne
zur seite und helfen ihnen dabei ein
vernünftiges gesetz eigentlich das
gesetz daraus zu machen herzlichen dank
fritz güntzler war das aus der
unionsfraktion und wer in dem moment in
der unionsfraktion von konstruktiver
opposition geredet wird dann löst das
reaktionen aus in der koalition haben
wir eben auch gemerkt der bundestag
diskutiert
erstmals über das
steuerentlastungsgesetz 20 22 und der
nächste redner zu diesem punkt ist
michael schrodi finanzpolitischer
sprecher der spd fraktion
sehr geehrte damen und herren herr
künstler opposition ist mist das wissen
aber deswegen muss doch das politische
leben eines oppositionspolitikers
nicht daraus bestehen das sammelsurium
nur anforderungen zu stellen die sich
übrigens nicht mal in dem antrag
teilweise wieder finden dieser vorgelegt
haben und die keine wirklich gezielten
maßnahmen für die aktuelle situation
darstellen konstruktive
oppositionspolitik müssen sie wahrlich
noch lernen muss
die funny mit allen auswirkungen
umsätzen 100 zusätzlichen steigen die
preise und teuerungsrate haben
zahlreiche bürgerinnen und bürger stark
belastet die grenze ihrer finanziellen
belastbarkeit
auch sie gebracht wir wollen diese
schwierige situation für verhältnisse
sorgen in dem alle menschen gut
zurechtkommen können die ampelkoalition
hat deshalb umfangreiche maßnahmen
beschlossen die wir jetzt umsetzen
werden die abschaffung der eeg-umlage
gehört dazu denn und verdoppelte
heizkostenzuschuss und eben auch in
einem gesamtpaket dieses
steuerentlastungsgesetz mit drei kern
maßnahmen die wir hier beschließen
werden die erhöhung des
arbeitnehmerpauschbetrags um 200 euro
rückwirkend zum ersten januar 2022
damit reduzieren wir das zu versteuernde
einkommen eine gute maßnahme sehr
geehrte damen und herren zweitens die
nacherhebung die entfernungspauschale
für fern pendelt was haben sie vor einem
monat noch gefolgt gesagt das sei ein
großer wurf wir machen das jetzt weil
wir wissen dass es natürlich eine höhere
belastung auch für pendlerinnen und
pendler gibt auch die wir reagieren
übrigens davon profitieren gibt es auch
geringverdiener damit erhöht sich auch
die mobilitäts prämie die diejenigen
bekommen die arbeiten aber nur ein
kleines gehalt beziehen die teile
steuern zahlen das ist glaube ich eine
wichtige maßnahme und ganz zentral ist
die anhebung des grundfreibetrags um
363 euro auf 10.000 347 euro ebenfalls
rückwirkend zum ersten januar das heißt
ganz konkret der teil des gehalts des
jahresgehalts auf den keine steuern
anfallen vergrößert sich es bleibt mehr
im geldbeutel und wir gleichen damit das
hat der herr bundesfinanzminister
richtig gesagt auf die wirkung der
kalten progression gerade für kleinere
mittlere einkommen aus und zwar so dass
alle einkommen steuerpflichtigen
gleichermaßen entlastet werden wobei man
dazusagen muss dass das relativ und
spürbar die entlastung für die bezieher
niedriger und mittlerer einkommen damit
hör und spürbar ist und das ist in der
situation wo gerade diejenigen am
meisten betroffen sind von den
steigenden gaspreisen vor allen dingen
das richtige mittel der wahl dass wir
hier auf dem weg in meine sehr geehrten
damen und herren
übrigens in das 4,5 milliarden nur mit
diesem ein gesetz dass wir auf den weg
bringen es sind über 30 milliarden die
wir mit unseren paketen insgesamt auf
den weg bringen ein großes volumen
und wir haben da einen teil bereits
schon vor dem überfall russlands auf die
ukraine auf den weg gebracht danach hat
die situation noch einmal verschärft wir
werden deshalb zusätzlich weitere maß
damit zu den aktuellen hinzufügen die
finanzierung die finanzielle
unterstützung für die bürgerinnen bürger
weitere auf den weg bringen wie
beispielsweise die energiepreis
pauschale in höhe von 300 euro als
zuschuss zum gehalt gerade das hilft
auch kleinen und mittleren einkommen zu
bekommen dieses geld direkt genauso wie
der familienzuschuss als einmal bonus
ergänzend zum kindergeld kenntnisse aus
der pandemie als kinderbonus auch da
gilt die geringverdiener die kleinen auf
die grundsicherung wird es nicht
angerechnet mit dem freibetrag aber wird
es gerade für höchste einkommen
verrechnet das heißt es von unten an und
diejenigen die ganz oben sind einkommen
bekommen es nicht ich finde das gerächt
weil es wieder eine gezielte maßnahme
ist für die menschen in diesem land das
heißt wir wollen dass alle menschen gut
zurechtkommen mit einem großen paket und
das eben gezielt ist das sozial
ausgewogen ist dass die adressiert die
am meisten diese mittel auch benötigen
und sie von der cdu/csu
aufgestanden muss man sich über den
antrag in zweierlei hinsicht einfach nur
wundern es ist erstens keine einzige
maßnahme herr dobrindt in diesen 12
geeignete irgendwie neu
die kleine mittlere einkommen wirklich
substanziell zu entlasten kein einziges
auf die aktuelle situation abgestimmt
das instrument einziger zuschuss keine
einzige wirkliche leistungserhöhung was
sie und das bundesland nrw und bayern
dafür fordern ist neben der anhebung des
grundfreibetrags auch jetzt eine
anhebung der eckwerte des
einkommenssteuertarifs
voran zu bringen was zusätzliche fünf
milliarden kosten würde und was sie
genau wissen vor allem höhere höchste
einkommen entlasten würden dass es in
dieser situation nicht das richtige
mittel der wahl meine sehr geehrten
damen und herren von zum zweiten muss
man sich darüber wundern warum sie hier
zu diesem gesetzentwurf herr kollege
dobrindt in einem antrag dinge fordern
die vornehmlich sagen der
unternehmensbesteuerung betreffen und
die wir in der übernächsten
tagesordnungspunkt mit dem vierten
kroner steuer hilfe gesetz auf den weg
bringen ich nenne hier exemplarisch
verbesserte abschreibungsmöglichkeiten
fragen das verlust vor ein rückzugsort
die verringerung erklärungen der
abgabefrist für steuerentlastungen es
sind alles maßnahmen die sich hier in
ihrem antrag finden der eigentlich ganz
andere dinge adressieren soll und die
wir jetzt in gut einer stunde auf den
weg bringen werden dass appel koalition
sie sollten bitteschön alle anträge
lesen und ihre anträge dann so aus
formulieren dass er wirklich passendes
in für diesen tagesordnungspunkt das
soll sich eine glatte themaverfehlung
ihr antrag weil es sehr geehrte damen
und herren wir
werden unser ziel alle bürgerinnen und
bürger gezielt zu entlasten auch mit
diesen
steuerentlastungsgesetz den voranbringen
wir wollen die bürgerinnen bürger
spürbar entlasten die gestiegenen preise
die teuerungsraten abdämpfen und da ist
die opposition herzlich eingeladen sich
konstruktiv an dieser debatte weiterhin
zu beteiligen darauf freue ich mich dann
auch gerne dann im ausschuss vielen dank
michael show die der finanzpolitische
sprecher der spd-fraktion in der ersten
beratung des bundestages zum
steuerentlastungsgesetz 20 22 es geht um
die anhebung des grundfreibetrags es
geht um die anhebung von pauschbeträgen
und es geht um die anhebung der
entfernungspauschale für fernpendler und
das geht um den nächsten redner und das
ist kein gottschalk der finanzpolitische
sprecher der fdp fraktion
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin sehr
geehrte kollegen vor allen dingen an
dieser stelle verehrte bürger und
steuerzahler
heute sprechen wir in erster lesung über
das so genannte
steuerentlastungsgesetz wohl lieber
ampel männchen und weibchen
selbstverständlich auch gebühren sehr
dass sie langsam in der realität
ankommen und entlastung für bürger auf
den weg bringen aufgrund der inflation
das fordern wir als afg schon sehr lange
da haben sie sich standhaft geweigert
aber wir sollten bei der wahrheit
bleiben eine der maßnahmen die sie hier
als entlastung anpreisen nämlich die
erhöhung des grundfreibetrages war und
ist nichts anderes als die freistellung
des einkommens steuerliche
existenzminimum
geld also was sie den bürger mit ihrer
verfehlten energiepolitik und
steuerpolitik vorher genommen haben
meine damen und herren ich
möchte sie an dieser stelle noch mal in
aller deutlichkeit daran erinnern und
das haben wir ja auch gestern und den
letzten tagen gesehen dass es mit der
rechtsstaatlichkeit und gesetzen nicht
so haben jetzt die tiere mit erlaubnis
der präsident und im beschluss des
zweiten senates vom 10 november 1998
unseres verfassungsgericht ist was sie
hoffentlich noch achten heißt es das
einkommen steuerlich existenzminimum ist
für alle steuerpflichtigen unabhängig
von ihren individuellen grenzsteuersatz
in voller höhe von der einkommen
steuerfrei zu stellen was sie hier also
tun ist gesetz und rechtsstaatlichkeit
und keine entlastung der bürger sie
geben ihnen das zurück was sie ihn durch
ihre informationen genommen meine damen
und herren
und wenn wir hier schon beim
grundfreibetrag sind sie stellen im
gesetzentwurf eine berechnung an wie sie
auf ihren wert von 10.000 347 euro kommt
das sind drei prozent der kollege
künstler hat es gesagt und sie nehmen
diese entlastung vor bei einer
inflationsrate von mittlerweile 74
prozent dann wissen wir heute zusammen
gefasst dass sie etwas was sie tun
müssen entlastungen und diese entlastung
sehenden auges viel zu gering ist und am
ende sie nicht mal den leitsatz des
bundesverfassungsgerichts erfüllen meine
damen und herren dass er nicht mal
rechtsbruch und
gut gedacht ist nicht immer gut gemacht
das trifft vor allem für
sozialdemokraten zu wir werden bei
dieser frage noch mal einen
änderungsantrag einbringen nachbessern
sie müssen hier deutlich erhöhen wir
werden einen vorschlag von mindestens 12
1600 euro hier ins spiel bringen und
ähnliches meine damen und herren geht
für die vorgezogene erhöhung der
entfernungspauschale
die spritpreise haben sich im vergleich
teilweise um 70 cent und mehr erhöht das
kann man übrigens gut gerade aber ich
glaube das ist so ideologischer
feindschaft das tun sie nicht beim adac
nachlesen wir reden ja also vom
preissteigerung von knapp 50 prozent
und dafür wird eine entfernungs
kostenpauschale die wir bürgerinnen und
bürger tun sie sich das an um nicht mal
ein zehntel und zwar ab dem 21 kilometer
erhöht das ist etikettenschwindel da
sage ich fühle was sie für die menschen
über haben die pendeln und jeden tag auf
ihrer maroden infrastruktur sich zur
arbeit fehlen meine damen und herren
und zu guter letzt ich kann es mir nicht
ersparen ich finde es schön fritz
güntzler liebe union sie sind in der
opposition angekommen herrlich
herzlichen glückwunsch ich persönlich
kann nämlich ihrem antrag viel
abgewinnen sie wissen auch warum
insbesondere beim punkt 5 musste ich
tatsächlich schmunzeln beim thema kalte
progression nähern wir uns offenbar
nämlich an also schön dass es endlich
einsehen insbesondere mit dem tarif auf
rädern in dem wir auch niederbringen bis
sie da entsprechend hoffentlich
reagieren dass sie da jetzt tatsächlich
wie gestern auch langsam auf der linie
kommen herzlichen glückwunsch liebe
union
aber um dauerhaft gegen unerwartet hohe
inflation etwas tun zu können sollten
wir eben nicht nur die tarifeckwerte der
einkommensteuer endlich indexiert wir
werden auch vorschlagen in den nächsten
wochen entsprechend automatische
anpassung der inflation vorzunehmen denn
sie könnten nicht meine damen und herren
von der ampel freibeträge frei ganz und
pauschbeträge sei es eben gesagt elf
jahre herr lindner elf jahre da waren
sie übrigens auch mal in der regierung
sind dann auch berechtigt rausgeflogen
prognostizieren ob bei der nächsten
bundestagswahl auch hier eine
automatische indexierung vorzunehmen
meine damen und herren und zu guter
letzt herr mordhorst nova anwesend ist
sie haben gesagt die tarifeckwerte
anpassung und der tarif auf rädern das
würde nicht gehen spinning audi ich
empfehle da eine sehr gute mathematische
abhandlung das können vielleicht noch
einige im hause eine simulation von
hans-georg petersen der zum fazit kommt
eine gerechte entlastung wird und ist
nur zu garantieren wenn man entsprechend
eine systematische index bindung von und
meine damen und herren wir werden sie
kritisch und fair begleiten durch die
beratung wir freuen uns drauf
insbesondere die cdu ich kann mich nur
wiederholen in der opposition angekommen
ist herzlichen glückwunsch danke
herr gottschalk gottschalk pardon für
die spd fraktion in der ersten beratung
des steuerentlastungsgesetzes 20 22 und
da steht schon bereit der nächste redner
wer kommt aus der fraktion bündnis
90/die grünen ist sascha müller und
sascha mölders ob man eben
finanzausschuss
[Applaus]
frau präsidentin sehr geehrte damen und
herren liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
heute diskutiert wird die politischen
antworten auf die hohen energiepreise
und damit im besonderen die steuerlichen
maßnahmen aus dem ersten entlastungs
paket der koalition
wahrscheinlich geht es ja uns allen nach
wie vor so wir sehen mit großer sorge
und entsetzen die ukrainische städte
bombardiert wohnhäuser und kliniken
beschossen werden mit jedem tag des
krieges 6 die note für die menschen in
der ukraine
ich denke das relativiert auch manche
auseinandersetzung die wir hier haben
als die ampel sich im februar auf das
erste entlastungs paket geeinigt hatte
spürten wir noch die hoffnung dass den
menschen der ukraine ein krieg erspart
bliebe und wir hoffen auch dass
steigende energiepreise und die damit
ausgelöste fossil getrieben inflation
nur eine temporäre erscheinung werden
könnten nun einen tag nach der
vorstellung des entlastungspaket das hat
er sich diese hoffnung auf grausamste
weise zerschlagen schnell war klar dass
wir ein zweites entlastungs paket
schnüren müssen auch dass sich die
koalition dann am 24 märz darauf
geeinigt hat mir ist wichtig zu betonen
dass beide entlastungspaket eine ganze
reihe von sehr gut aufeinander
abgestimmten maßnahmen beinhalten es
sind maßnahmen darunter für die breite
der gesellschaft aber insbesondere für
jene die es ganz besonders hart trifft
weil die fonds die fossil betriebene
inflation die gestiegenen energiepreise
nicht so einfach wegstecken können
unterstreiche
das deshalb weil die einzelnen maßnahmen
nicht isoliert soll den kontext mit den
anderen maßnahmen gesehen werden müssen
wie zum beispiel die frühere abschaffung
der eeg umlage oder dem
heizkostenzuschuss
hier und heute geht das also um die
steuerlichen aspekte und dabei um drei
maßnahmen aus dem ersten paket vom
februar der grundfreibetrag wird erhöht
der arbeitnehmerpauschbetrag ebenso wo
die pendlerpauschale wird angehoben die
anhebung des grundfreibetrags um 363
euro auf 10.000 347 euro rückwirkend zum
jahresbeginn gehört zu den maßnahmen die
die ganze breite der gesellschaft
entlasten denn sie kommt allen einkommen
steuerzahlerin einkommensteuerzahler
zugute die zweite maßnahme betrifft die
anhebung des arbeitnehmerpauschbetrags
auch dies eine erleichterung und sie
bedeutet gleichzeitig eine erhebliche
steuervereinfachung mehr
arbeitnehmerinnen und arbeitnehmer
können so auf das lange rechnet von
arbeitswegen und das sammeln von belegen
für ihre werbungskosten verzichten weil
dies von der höheren pauschale abgedeckt
ist und
zur dritten maßnahme ja die vorgezogene
aber weiter befristete anhebung der
pendlerpauschale ab dem 21 kilometer
zugegeben da hätten wir uns in der
fraktion auch andere wege vorstellen
können aber natürlich sehen wir die
erhöhte belastung für pendlerinnen und
pendler insbesondere für diejenigen die
keine alternative zum auto haben aber
die wirkung der pendlerpauschale bleibt
noch mal unter ökologischen
gesichtspunkten diskutabel und aspekten
der verteilungsgerechtigkeit auch
vielleicht kontraproduktiv wohlhabender
profitieren sehr viel mehr als arme wer
sich ein größeres auto leisten kann und
dann vielleicht einen großen suv fährt
er hat erhält eine größere
steuerentlastung als diejenigen die sich
nur den kleinen wagen mit deutlich
geringerem ausstoß leisten können um so
mehr froh bin ich darüber dass wir in
der koalition zusammen mit spd und fdp
vereinbart haben die pendlerpauschale
noch in dieser legislatur ökologisch und
sozial neu auszurichten hier liegen
bereits interessante konzepte auf dem
tisch wir werden auch auf die agenda
setzen
mit dem energie geld was sie an zweiten
entlastungspaket mit der energiepreis
pauschale bereits ein stück weit
vorwegnehmen dass eine ökologische
soziale sinnvolle maßnahme bereits in
arbeit und liebe freuen kolleginnen und
kollegen von der union hier vorliegende
antrag
gibt mir die gelegenheit zu einer
grundsätzlichen bemerkungen
meine fraktion war ja in der
vergangenheit lange für meinen geschmack
zu lange in der opposition 100 sich
dabei konstruktiv kritisch im bundestag
mit eigenen vorschlägen ein gibt auch
das etwas was ich von der größten
oppositionsfraktion derzeit noch zur
seltene höhere der vorliegende antrag
der union wie ihn hatte in der tat eine
reihe von eigenen forderungen ist dann
würde somit schon mal ein kleiner
fortschritt es gab in meiner fraktion in
der oppositionsarbeit aber noch eine
andere maxime er dem ich auch als damals
noch nicht parlament aber gefreut hat
dich immer richtig fand fordern
opposition nichts was du nicht in der
regierung selbst umsetzen würde ist das
auch eine frage von glaubwürdigkeit und
das wird nichts mit dem vorigen antrag
noch nicht gegeben denn ganz ehrlich
liebe union sind sie wirklich sicher
dass sie diesen forderungskatalog auch
angegangen umgesetzt hätten wenn sie
noch in der regierung werden in dieser
schwierigen zeit wirklich ich habe da
meine zweifel
ich weiß nicht ob die lange liste die
uns kollege otto fricke zum aus ändert
der haushaltsberatung letzten
sitzungswoche so eindrucksvoll
präsentiert hat mit diesem antrag noch
länger geworden ist aber glauben sie
meinen sie es wirklich ernst dass sie
hier ein paket schnüren können in dieser
situation mit noch so viel unbekannt für
unsere zukunft das einfach mal die
gießkanne auspackt in keinster weise
zielgerichtet ist um bund länder und
kommunen viele weitere milliarden kosten
würde diese milliarden brauchen wir
lieber für die kommenden jahr wirklich
schwierigen aufgaben und
es ist eben jetzt nicht die zeit dafür
die große gießkanne auszupacken sondern
wir müssen da helfen wo es am meisten
brennt bei den bürgerinnen und bürgern
und eben auch und da werden wir wenn es
wenn es nötig ist auch handeln auch bei
dem unternehmen ich möchte zum schluss
noch die gelegenheit nutzen auf ein wort
hinzuweisen dass der csu-vorsitzende
beispiel ministerpräsident markus söder
seit dem sonntag versucht etablieren
einmal das bild einen angeblichen
hyperinflation angewandt der begriff
nicht bewusst gewählt nicht aus sie
würde dann zu emotionalisieren
auch wenn wir über die frage die welche
reagieren in diesem hohen haus
kontrovers diskutieren sollten wir alle
die in verantwortung stehen es vermeiden
in diesen uns alle herausforderungen
zeiten ängste zu schüren liebe kollegen
und kollegen von der union wenn sich ein
einfluss haben dann reden sie bitte mit
markus söder das über ich danke für die
aufmerksamkeit
sascha müller für die fraktion bündnis
90/die grünen und damit für die ampel
koalition insgesamt denn die liegt
diesen gesetzentwurf über den ihr seit
kurz nach neuen diskutiert wird bevor
und geht es jetzt weiter mit einer
sogenannten koinzidenz sehen die zwei
redner die sich jetzt gleich
hintereinander hören die haben sie heute
worden auch bei uns schon sehen und
hören können das beginnt christian görke
für die linksfraktionen
steigt die inflation nicht nur die
gefühlte und entwertet meine damen und
herren ihre entlastungs paket von der
koalition besonders ihr erstes
entlastungspaket ist ja nun wirklich
nicht ziehen oder studi nehmen wir mal
die erhöhung der pendlerpauschale
abgesehen davon dass bei ihren plänen
weiterhin viele kinder trotz höheren
pauschbetrag ist so gut wie leer
ausgehen profitieren vor allen dingen
das wissen sie die die viel fahren ja
aber auch die die hohe einkommen
versteuern können und meine damen und
herren von den 300.000 die in
brandenburg pendeln fallen bei ihren
plänen ein drittel durch das raster
meine damen und herren der koalition sie
sagen ja immer sie sind die fortschritts
koalition und könnten ja an und werden
jetzt an so vielen stellschrauben also
richtig drehen wäre schön wenn sie an
den richtigen drehen und richtige
präzise vorschläge machen bbs um mit dem
einstieg in ein mobilitäts geld um eine
faire und vor allen dingen verbrauch
gerechte entlastung unabhängig vom
einkommen zu schaffen insofern hätte ich
gerade von den grünen aber von den user
oder den linken in der spd erwartet als
vor einigen tagen die tür für diese
diskussion aufging dass sie sich für
eine reform der pendlerpauschale
eingesetzt hätten und dass wir dann auch
ein mobilitäts geld bekommen da haben
wir gesehen ergebnis liegt auf dem tisch
und wenn denn selbst heute meine damen
und herren selbst die cdu schon von
einem mobilitäts geld träumen ja das
muss ihn doch zu denken geben aber
anscheinend gilt ja in der ampel das
motto wenn wir entlasten denn dann
lassen wir mal die spitzeneinkommen
gleich mal mit wissen sie was das erste
des fdp-politik eins zu eins so weit zum
fortschritt dieser position in der
studie aber mal ehrlich zur energiepreis
pauschale einmalig 300 euro brutto netto
beträge kennen sie sicherlich selbst ist
müsste ihnen aufgefallen sein dass bei
diesen bei diesen
inflationsentwicklungen die
entwicklungen doch regelrecht verpuffen
und meine damen und lese ich nicht
ausreden sich nicht auf und dass sie
dass sie als sozialdemokraten bei diesem
entlastungspaket auch nur auf die
erwerbstätigen setzen und die
rentnerinnen und rentner millionen von
rentnerinnen und rentner einfach nicht
berücksichtigt haben macht nicht nur
mich fassungslos sondern die
wohlfahrtsverbände und
andro
und wissen sie diese renterinnen und
rentner haben jahrelang mal lobt und ich
kann mich noch entsinnen da haben sie
vor sechs monaten
den respekt eingefordert der sogar
plakatiert es wäre an der zeit dass sie
jetzt noch umkehren und den
parlamentarischen prozess dies noch mal
revidieren das erwarten nicht nur wir
von ihnen meine damen und herren
zur energie steuer die senkung war
richtig angesichts dieser preis
explosion aber wenn die logistiker die
taxiunternehmen die 4000 unternehmen
nicht pleite gehen soll muss die
steuersenkung länger als drei monate
laufen es braucht jetzt verlässliche
lösung keine wunderkerzen die schon nach
drei monaten abgefackelt sind und ich
beziehen
und nicht prophezeien schon jetzt dass
sie auf unsere vorschläge wieder
zurückkommen wollen die eine verlegung
dieser maßnahmen mindestens auf sechs
monate zum inhalt haben und erzählen sie
mir bitte nicht etwas vom geld wer
schafft bei der bundeswehr an der
schuldenbremse verbreiten zu lassen er
schafft auch eine finanzierung für eine
sozial ausgewogene belastung der
bürgerinnen und bürger hinzubekommen
vielen dank
sagt ist hier ein görke der
finanzpolitische sprecher der
linksfraktion und ihm folgt jetzt der
finanzpolitische sprecher der fdp
fraktion markus herbrand und wenn sie um
viertel vor neun schon bei uns gewesen
sind haben sie ein wenig von seinen
positionen auch schon mitbekommen können
vielen dank frau präsidentin liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen nichts zu tun
ist in dieser lage keine option das hat
der bundesfinanzminister eben gesagt und
dafür danke ich ihnen ganz herzlich
denn mit diesem steuerentlastungsgesetz
22 hat die ampel fortschritts koalition
ungewöhnlich schnell verantwortung im
bereich der finanz und steuerpolitik für
unser land übernommen
wir
geben mit diesem entlastungspaket eine
antwort auf eine andauernde krise denn
die ursache für dieses entlastungs paket
sind nicht die auswirkungen des krieges
sondern die auch von experten in der
höhe und der dauer nicht angenommene
inflation in deutschland und liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen politik vermag
weder für eine niedrige inflation zu
sorgen noch kann sie alles ausgleichen
was zu einer
teuerungsrate führt aber was sie zu
leisten imstande ist das macht die ampel
hier wir setzen ein zeichen die
bürgerinnen und bürger können sich auf
diese regierung verlassen wir lassen
niemanden allein
herr kollege verbrannt und starten wir
eine zwischenbemerkungen dazwischen
frage von frau lötzsch aus der fraktion
die linke sie haben das wort fritsche
vielen dank herr kollege sie haben eben
den satz wiederholt den auch herr
lindner gesagt hat der staat kann ich
alles ausgleichen die frage ist nur was
ist die alternative
ich finde an dieser stelle wäre es doch
nötig den unternehmen zusagen bezahlt
euro leute anständig damit der staat ist
eben nicht ausgleichen muss und die
haben ja beispiele von unternehmen die
in zb in ballungsgebieten einen zuschuss
zahlen für die mobilität oder ein
zuschuss für die mietkosten während das
nicht die richtige forderung die man
stellen muss anstatt zu sagen der staat
kann nicht alles ausgleichen was ja so
ein bisschen suggeriert neue leute
stellt euch auf kürzungen ein also die
forderung unterstützen sie die an die
unternehmen zeit eure leute
ständig
es gehört frau kollegin zur wahrheit
dazu dass der staat in einer solchen
hohen inflation lage nicht alles wird
ausgleichen können und wenn sie das den
menschen suggerieren dann ist das falsch
in meinen augen
wir entlasten die menschen mit der
erhöhung des grundfreibetrages werden
wir die steuer wirkungen der inflation
anpassen da hatte sich die alte
regierung ja deutlich verrechnet und her
günstiger wenn sie uns jetzt hier
vorwerfen dass wir die kalte progression
nicht rechtzeitig ausgleichen dann ist
das ja schon
vorsichtig ausgedrückt witzig denn sie
hatten ja 16 jahre die zeit dass auch
rechtzeitig immer zu machen das haben
sie nicht gemacht und mit der
vorgezogenen erhöhung erfahrungs
pauschale für fernpendler versuchen wir
einen ausgleich für arbeitnehmerinnen
und
arbeitnehmer
zu erreichen die längere strecken mit
dem auto zu ihrer arbeitsstätte
zurücklegen müssen das ist nämlich die
lebenswirklichkeit ganz vieler menschen
in diesem land und wir erhöhen die
arbeit den arbeitnehmer pauschbetrag bei
der einkommensteuer dauerhaft das ist
gleichzeitig entlastend wie auch
entbürokratisieren das ist auch eben
schon angesprochen worden und auch hier
muss man die berechnungen die eben
angenommen angenommen worden sind von
der union das muss man natürlich
zusammen sehen den arbeitnehmer
pauschbetrag und die
entfernungspauschale das gehört zusammen
gedacht und wenn ich nicht wüsste dass
es besser wüssten herr günster würde ich
dann heute noch annehmen dazu kommen
noch aus anderen gesetzen die
abschaffung der eeg umlage ab juli an
4000 kilowattstunden verbrauchen als
haushalt bringt das eine entlastung von
circa 180 euro eine dauerhafte
abschaffung und der heizkostenzuschuss
für menschen mit geringem einkommen
sowie ein sofort zuschlag für von armut
bedrohten bedrohten kindern in höhe von
20 euro im monat
meine sehr verehrten
kolleginnen und kollegen dieses gesamte
entlastungspaket hat insgesamt ein gut
von circa 16 milliarden euro die ampel
hat hier sehr effektiv wirtschaftlich
vernünftig und vor allem auch sozial
ausgewogen gehandelt sie hat damit ihre
handlungsfähigkeit unter beweis gestellt
und diejenigen die jetzt immer laut
rufen das ist zu wenig zu langsam zu
bürokratisch die sollten ihre eigenen
leistungen in der vergangenheit einmal
kritisch hinterfragen danke
markus herbrand noch mal mit einer
anmerkung in richtung
unionsfraktion und aus der kommt auch
der nächste redner in dieser debatte in
der es um das steuerentlastungsgesetz 20
22 geht um höhere grundfreibeträge um
höhere beträge und um eine anhebung der
entfernungspauschale für fernpendler
nächster redner wie gesagt aus der
unionsfraktion sebastian brehm csu
landesgruppe kolleginnen und kollegen
heute beraten hier in der ersten lesung
das sogenannte steuerentlastungsgesetz
2022 der ampel regierung es geht im
wesentlichen um die erhöhung des
grundfreibetrags um 363 euro die
anhebung des arbeitnehmerpauschbetrags
und 200 euro und die erhöhung der
pendlerpauschale und drei cent ab dem 21
kilometer das ist das erste paket der
ampel vor dem ukraine krieg was ist mit
dem zweiten paket was ist mit der
reduzierung des sprits was ist mit der
reduzierung der energie steuer auf den
sprit dieses paket wollen sie von den
grünen bereits schon wieder kassieren
herr kollege janitschek
hat er ein interview der augsburger
allgemeinen zeitung gegeben und hat
gesagt warum sollen wir benzin und
diesel bei diesem niveau noch teuer
subventionieren und hier gibt es in der
regierungskoalition wieder uneinigkeit
und die maßnahmen werden zunächst wieder
auf eis gelegt zu lasten der bürgerinnen
und bürger bei einer nicht gefühlten
sondern bestehenden rekord inflation und
extremen preissteigerungen in allen
bereichen und das ist ehrlich gesagt
völlig unzureichend denn die bürgerinnen
und bürger brauchen jetzt eine
entlastung und nicht erst in ein paar
monaten wenn sie sich vielleicht in der
regierungskoalition einigen können das
ist keine entlastungs politik sondern
chaos politik zu lasten der bürgerinnen
und bürger liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen
zur sicherung der arbeitsplätze herr
kollege schrodi sie sagen sie machen der
weitreichende vorschläge zur sicherung
von arbeitsplätzen und unternehmen die
spielen in diesem gesetz für die ampel
übrigens keine rolle denn für
unternehmen gibt es keine notwendigen
entlastungen auch übrigens in dem chor
ohne steuer hilfe gesetz ist es marginal
auch die rasant steigenden preise
übrigens herr kollege schrodi sind
existenziell für die unternehmen und für
die arbeitsplätze in unserem land und
sie tun gar nichts liebe kolleginnen
kollegen von der ampel
was ist aus ihren versprechen geworden
herr lindner sie haben zahlreiche
anträge gestellt in der opposition im
wahlprogramm versprochen ich möchte nur
zwei dinge zitieren der staat profitiert
von rekord steuereinnahmen bei bürgern
kommt davon nichts an auch die
unternehmen warten bisher vergeblich auf
entlastungen und weiter beim
einkommensteuertarif wollen wir den
mittelstandsbauch vollständig abschaffen
heute steigt die steuerlast bei kleinen
und mittleren einkommen besonders
schnell von gehaltserhöhungen greift
sich der staat mehr als die hälfte das
ist leistungsfeindlich und ungerecht
ich kann das nur unterschreiben was in
ihrem wahlprogramm steht ich kann das
nur unterschreiben aber sie haben doch
die möglichkeit jetzt als finanzminister
das umzusetzen lieber kollege müller sie
haben gesagt man sollte in der
opposition nur das fordern was man
hinterher auch umsetzt dann frage ich
sie warum setzen sie diese maßnahmen
jetzt nicht um
der grundfreibetrag steigt um 363 euro
das entspricht einer erhöhung von 6,2
prozent
der sachverständigenrat geht für dieses
jahr von einer inflation übrigens noch
vor märz und noch ohne ukraine krieg von
6,1 prozent aus deshalb reicht die
erhöhung des grundfreibetrages nicht aus
die kalte progression nur im ansatz zu
beseitigen und lieber herr kollege herr
brand wir haben das gemacht sie machen
das jetzt nicht die folge ihre politik
ist
eine schmälerung der wirtschaftlichen
leistungsfähigkeit der steuerpflichtigen
die regierung nimmt wohlstandsverluste
einfach hin statt eine strategie für
neue perspektiven zu schaffen sowohl
wirtschaftsminister habe ich als auch
finanzminister linden annehmen dieses
hin und sagen das auch noch öffentlich
sie nehmen einfach das zur kenntnis dass
die menschen ärmer werden und sie tun
nichts dagegen was sie heute vorschlagen
liebe kolleginnen kollegen ist ein
tropfen auf den heißen stein
wir brauchen wir brauchen zumindest
einen vollständigen ausgleich der
auswirkungen der kalten progression und
eine deutliche verschiebung der
steuerkurve nach rechts und zur
pendlerpauschale vielleicht noch
abschließend zur pendlerpauschale
abschließend noch 80 prozent der
berufspendler sind laut statistischem
bundesamt weniger als 25 kilometer zu
ihrer arbeitsstätte unterwegs wenn wir
das ganze einmal großzügig durchrechnen
übrigens schwache leistung ist es was
sie hier vorschlagen das ist eine
schwache leistung lieber kollege rudi
nichts andere ihr gesetz ist eine
schwache leistung
wenn wir die pendlerpauschale und ihre
erhöhung einmal großzügig durchrechnen
dann ist für 80 prozent der pendler
macht das 10 euro im jahr aus das reicht
nicht einmal für eine tankfüllung liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen machen sie doch
wenigstens die pendlerpauschale ab dem
ersten kilometer höher das wäre richtig
liebe kolleginnen kollegen
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen es gibt
keine strategie der bundesregierung
gegen inflation es gibt keine strategie
der bundesregierung gegen steigende
energiepreise und es gibt keine
strategie der bundesregierung gegen
steigende lebensmittelpreise die
regierung darauf die verluste der bürger
doch nicht einfach nur verbuchen sie
muss sie verhindern liebe kolleginnen
kollegen deswegen tun sie was und
bessern sie in diesem gesetz nach ich
danke herzlich für ihre aufmerksamkeit
so was gern bremen für die unions
fraktion im finanzausschuss
und auch der nächste redner ist mitglied
im finanzausschuss carlos kasper retter
seien aus der spd-fraktion und es geht
nach wie vor um das
steuerentlastungsgesetz 20 22
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin sehr
geehrte kolleginnen und kollegen wir
stehen derzeit vor großen
herausforderungen
die gestiegenen energiekosten belasten
uns alle vor allem aber treffen sie
kleine und mittlere einkommen ich
vertrete das kennen wir zwar umland ihr
im bundestag das ist eine eher ländlich
geprägte region es gibt viele
kleinstädte und dörfer der pnv ist nicht
gut ausgebaut und die menschen sind auf
ihr auto angewiesen
das gilt insbesondere für diejenigen die
in schichten arbeiten und zb nachts ist
in das vw werk nach mosel pendeln müssen
oder zur frühschicht in das krankenhaus
nach liechtenstein aber gerade zu diesen
zeiten gibt es eben keine busse und
bahnen die fragen
viele frauen schlichtweg ihr auto wenn
sie zur arbeit kommen wollen das
chemnitzer umland aber auch ganz sachsen
ist leider auch eine region mit sehr
niedrigen löhnen beispielsweise wird
fast die hälfte der im erzgebirge
beschäftigten menschen von der
mindestlohn erhöhung im november
profitieren aber wie soll jemand da noch
nicht mal zwölf euro pro stunde verdient
jetzt auch noch die gestiegenen sprit
und heizkosten stellen sie können es
sich schlichtweg nicht leisten noch mehr
geld für sprit heizkosten und
nahrungsmittel auszugehen und deswegen
brauchen wir jetzt und heute entlastung
mit dem steuerentlastungspaket setzen
wir genau da an wir bringen einen ganzen
strauß voller maßnahmen auf den weg die
direkt bei den menschen ankommt und die
direkt wirken wir werden die energie
steuern auf diesel und benzin
vorübergehend auch unbefristet ganz
konkret heißt das auf benzin wird 30
cent billiger und diese 14 cent das
kommt allen zugute nicht nur den
abhängig beschäftigten sondern auch den
kleinen und mittleren betrieben die auf
ihr auto angewiesen sind und zb
auf mit dem auto zur arbeit harmlosen
der ambulante pflegedienst oder den klar
der kleine handwerksbetrieb von nebenan
bei dieser vorübergehenden steuersenkung
ist mir eins aber ganz besonders wichtig
wir müssen die konzerne dazu
verpflichten diese steuersenkung direkt
weiterzugeben die preise müssen an der
zapfsäule sinken und auch kein teil das
sich wiederholen was wir in den
vergangenen wochen gesehen haben
raffinerien haben die spritpreise
überdurchschnittlich getrieben und damit
unverschämter gewinne gemacht und
ich bin mir sicher dass insbesondere
auch das finanzministerium
auf die weitergabe der senkung achtet
sehr geehrte damen und herren eine
weitere maßnahme die wir auf den weg
bringen ist die erhöhung der
pendlerpauschale
wer mehr als 21 kilometer zur arbeit
fährt kann künftig 68 38 cent pro
kilometer über die steuererklärung
abrechnen diese regelung über
rückwirkend am ersten januar gelten und
befristet sein bis 2026 auch wie hier
haben wir die menschen im ländlichen
raum im blick aber es sind nicht nur die
gestiegenen spritpreise die uns vor
großen herausforderungen stellen auch
die heizkosten explodieren derzeit
deswegen bringen wir ein weiteres
wirklich sehr wichtiges instrument auf
den weg jede arbeitnehmerin jeder
selbständige erhält 300 euro als
direktzahlung zum ausgleich auf die
hohen heizkosten
dieses geld kommt schnell bei den
menschen an und das sichtbar auf jeden
lohnzettel beziehungsweise weiter
steuervorauszahlungen es ist nicht nur
schnell wirksam sondern auch sehr sozial
denn die 300 euro werden mit der
einkommenssteuer gegengerechnet wir
entlasten hier also insbesondere
geringverdienende die sowieso kaum
einkommenssteuer zahlen
sehr geehrte damen und herren wir
befinden uns in eine krise aber in der
krise liegt auch eine chance eine chance
langfristig die weichen für eine soziale
und nachhaltige zukunft zu stellen jetzt
ist der richtige moment um umfassend in
erneuerbaren energien zu investieren
jetzt ist der richtige moment um
wegzukommen von fossilen energieträgern
und jetzt ist der richtige moment um den
sozialstaat so auszurüsten dass
diejenigen mit kleinem geldbeutel diese
transformation mitgehen können
wir sozialdemokratinnen und
sozialdemokraten sind bereit diesen
moment zu nutzen deswegen haben wir uns
stark gemacht für soziale instrumente
deswegen führen wir die direktzahlungen
1 und deswegen greifen wir
verbraucherinnen und verbraucher bei der
mit der befristeten energie
steuersenkung unter die arme wir schauen
gerade auch in den ländlichen raum und
den lasten hier gezielt diejenigen die
sich schlichtweg mobilität nicht mehr
leisten können in meiner ersten rede im
bundestag habe ich gesagt wir machen
politik die wirkt an diesen entlastungs
paket sieht man dass sie wirkt und zwar
sozusagen gerecht
liebe kollegen könnten sie die
unterhaltung an der regierungsbank an
einer anderen stelle fortführen oder
gar nicht mehr auch gut
so da gibt es eine ermahnung die
untertags präsidentin für gespräche an
der regierungsbank und avia christian
lindner eben wir gesehen haben gleich
noch ein hinweis 13.30 werden wir ihn
mutmaßlich auch in diesem programm
wieder sehen gemeinsam mit robert habeck
denn es ist alles in allem große
entlassungstag in einführungszeiten
heute offenbar hier wird über
steuerentlastungen geredet später dann
noch mal aber die minister lindner und
harbeck wollen auch weitere hilfen für
die wirtschaft vorstellen dann um 13.30
wir haben erstmal dem abgeordneten klaus
stöber aus der fdp fraktion zu es
mitglied im finanzausschuss
beleidigen sie eigentlich nicht nur
geeignet wenn
wir mal die pendlerpauschale kollegen
künstler und bremen haben schon hand
gesprungen warum eigentlich ist aber 21
kilometer ich weiß nicht wann das letzte
mal tank sie können es ja mal probieren
der tankstelle zu fahren so zu sagen ich
will mal für die ersten 20 liter weniger
bezahlen das für den rest ich denke mal
das wird ein interessantes gespräch
werden und dann längere 30 cent ab dem
21 1 kilometer ich weiß nicht ob sie das
schon mal durchgerechnet haben ich habe
es für siege tagen bei 30 kilometer
entfernung sind das 68 euro
werbungskosten mehr im jahr mit 30
prozent steuersatz sind als 21 euro
steuererstattungen gleichzeitig hat
einer 30 kilometer entfernung er
verteile doppelte strecke rund 1000 euro
mehrkosten durch sprit aus 21 euro
entlastung stehen 1000 euro
mehrbelastung gegenüber das nennen sie
steuerentlastung
sehr guter minister aber drin was ist
kein sport fast ins gesetz das ist kein
aprilscherz und liebe belegen der cdu ja
ich habe mir dann ein paar angeschaut
das in viele dollars vernünftige
vorschläge enthalten aber gut zu
wesentlichen steuerlichen maßnahmen wird
ist es nicht den mut wäre es wenn sie
sagen wollen die herzliche
steuergesetzgebung ist komplett er vor
mir bedürftig wir haben 31 prozent
steuersatz in deutschland das heißt den
höchsten der ganzen welt wir haben die
tatsache dass jemand mit 58.000 euro
einkommen bereits den spitzensteuersatz
bezahlt und das bleibt so bis zu 277
1000 euro das ist doch nicht gerecht ja
alles noch keine spitzenverdiener dass
ingenieure ist ein lehrer da sind gut
verdienende facharbeiter und kleine und
mittlere unternehmen aber keine
spitzenverdiener und die 58.000 euro
einkommen haben und die zahl 42 prozent
steuersatz und sie haben noch genügend
fachleute in ihrer fraktionen um dieses
problem anzugreifen und sieht uns aber
auch nicht deswegen kann ich internets
versprechen wir als fdp fraktion werde
noch in diesem jahr ein umfassendes
gesetz zur steuerentlastung vorlegen und
dann liegt es an ihnen und ich auch an
kollegen lindner das dann hier in der
praxis umzusetzen vielen dank
klaus stöber reif die fraktion als zwei
minuten schneller fertig als ich
eigentlich angekündigt gewesen ist ich
kann sie verweisen meine damen und
herren damen und herren ich auf das
kleine bild das sie links sehen wir
erwarten um 10 uhr die pressekonferenz
mit dem bundesgesundheitsminister karl
lauterbach mit terry präsident wieder
und mit gernot markt hier präsidenten
der deutschen interdisziplinären
vereinigung für intensiv und
notfallmedizin dagegen wir live drauf
das programm des bundestages werden wir
ihn hin weiter ausstrahlen über unsere
youtube und facebook kanäle und bis es
soweit jetzt hören wir auch auf diese
maus spiel weg noch mal ein in lisa paus
wollte ich sagen stimmt aber gar nicht
denn sie sehen bewegungen in der
bundespressekonferenz die angekündigten
protagonisten sind auf dem weg zu ihren
plätzen ich vermute mal dass das bild
über kurz oder lang dann auch größer
sein wird und sie die bereits
angesprochenen
herren in diesem fall dann auch sehen
werden und diese pressekonferenz dann
auch beginnt so dass ich an dieser
stelle jetzt abgeben
die bundespressekonferenz nicht unweit
des reichstagsgebäudes und wie gesagt
alle die debatte weiter verfolgen wollen
denen lege ich unseren youtube und
facebook kanal ans herz
[Applaus]
eben freizustellen inflation zu begegnen
und wir erhöhen auch den arbeitnehmer
pauschbetrag und wir ändern auch was bei
der pendlerpauschale
dieses gesetz ist nur ein teil des
gesamten paketes was bereits beschlossen
ist von der bundesregierung es kommt
noch die sozial gerechte energiepreis
pauschale es konnten auch einen
familienbonus wir schaffen die eeg
umlage ab wir haben bereits die
heizkostenpauschale
erhöht und auf weitere teile werden
folgen wichtig ist in diesem
zusammenhang natürlich auch jenseits
dieser steuerlichen finanziellen dinge
dass wir so schnell wie möglich raus
kommen aus der abhängigkeit von
russischem öl von erdgas und von kohle
aus russland
und das machen wir auch mit vielerlei
instrumenten ein bitterer punkt ist dass
wir eben nicht vollständig sofort raus
können dass wir in gewisser weise eine
shoppen diversifizierung jetzt betreiben
ein zweiter wichtiger punkt ist aber
dass wir beim thema energieeffizienz
jetzt wirklich den turbo anlegen und das
haben wir auch mit dem zweiten
steuerentlastungspaket nochmal verankert
der verbrauch von energie der muss auch
deutlich sinken wir können das nicht
alles über preis und rationierung machen
meine damen und herren und deswegen
helfen wir auch jeden bürgerinnen und
bürgern in dem wir eben auf einfachen
maßen haben wir zum beispiel den
hydraulischen abgleich der heizung ja
dass wir das unterstützen dass wir
heizungs austausch zusätzlich
unterstützen das auch so dinge wie
thermostate auswechseln man kann mit
kleinen dingen schon richtig was leisten
jede kilowattstunde die eingespart wird
die ist wirklich wichtig und dafür haben
wir die sommerzeit um dann auch im
winter besser dazustehen auch hier
unterstützt die regierung
und
das große paket das sogenannte ist auf
den weg gebracht das heißt wir machen
wir überhaupt eine deutliche
beschleunigung im bereich des ausbaus
der erneuerbaren energien wo werden wir
unabhängig von russland
so werden wir aber auch unabhängig von
fossiler inflation und das thema hatten
wir leider auch schon vor dem ukraine
krieg der hat es nochmal deutlich
verschärft das thema fossile inflation
das ist etwas was ohnehin schon anstand
und mit dieser beschleunigung schaffen
wir es auch das große problem der
inflation wieder in den griff zu
bekommen meine damen und herren
trotzdem wir sind hier in richtig
schweren zeiten so eine inflationsrate
die hat deutschland praktisch seit den
70er jahren nicht gesehen die drohen
tatsächlich eine stagnation zu rutschen
es gibt furchtbare zahlen
unterschiedliche szenarien jetzt schon
von entsprechenden ökonomen ökonomen und
umso drastischer und furchtbarer finde
ich ehrlich gesagt den umgang der cdu
mit dieser situation der antrag der
heute vorliegt in der tat ich kennen
ganz viele von den forderungen darin
stehen weil das evergreens sind aus der
letzten legislaturperiode die cdu damals
mit der spd verhandelt hat mit der spd
nicht hinbekommen hat so weit so ok aber
dieser antrag hat nichts mit der
aktuellen situation zu tun ist überhaupt
nicht angenommen überhaupt nicht
angemessen und deswegen könnte ich mir
einen starken schlussmann und sagen
super haben wir halt eine schwache
opposition wie gut für die regierung
aber in diesen zeiten in diesen zeiten
brauchen wir eine starke demokratie und
parlamentarismus funktioniert über eine
gute regierung und eine gute opposition
und in diesem sinne in diesem sinne
bitte ich sie insbesondere von der union
ich freue mich schon auf entsprechende
änderungsanträge im
gesetzgebungsverfahren nutzen sie ihre
chance hier in diesem hause
[Applaus]
nächster redner für die cdu csu fraktion
dr michael meister
frau präsidentin liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen
ich finde es ist ein richtiger gedanke
dass die bundesregierung heute in der
situation in der wir sind einen
vorschlag für ein steuerentlastungs
2022 vorlegt und das begrüßen wir auch
grundsätzlich dass ein solcher vorschlag
kommt
allerdings will ich darauf hinweisen der
bundesfinanzminister hat eingangs von
einer gefühlten inflation gesprochen
lieber herr kollege lindner ich glaube
in der lage in der wir sind haben wir
keine gefühlte inflation
sondern wir haben eine objektive
inflation eine inflation die im märz bei
7,3 prozent lag
und die kommt wirklich bei den menschen
im geldbeutel an und sie haben hier ein
steuerentlastungsgesetz vorgelegt was
auf eine annahme passiert kollege
künstlers vorhin angesprochen von drei
prozent inflation
das ist die hälfte dessen was wir
tatsächlich haben und deshalb sage ich
ihnen der gedanke ist richtig aber er
greift wesentlich zu kurz hier muss
deutlich mehr geschehen
sie schlagen vor beim arbeitnehmer
pauschbetrag 200 euro schlagen vor beim
grundfreibetrag
263 euro und dann wird so schön
formuliert von den kollegen aus der
koalition
naja der grundfreibetrag der hilft dir
alle steuerzahler weil jedem kommt der
grundfreibetrag zugute ich will aber an
der stelle mal darauf hinweisen dass sie
die anderen tarif eckwerte nicht
anfassen und was heißt das denn diana
tarifeckwerte nicht anfassen das heißt
sie bleiben wie sie sind und das heißt
wenn sie sich das anschauen sie rücken
den grundfreibetrag nach rechts und
erweist bleibt dadurch wäre der
steuertarif steiler das heißt die
grenzbelastung wächst das was sie hier
tun ist leistungsfeindlich und
eigentlich auch mit der situation
anderer als motivation zur leistung und
keine leistungsfeindliche politik
und ich finds ja net verpasst dass sie
eben gesagt haben sie warten auf die
vorschläge der opposition
wir haben an der stelle einen klaren
vorschlag gemacht wir möchten alle
tarifeckwerte verändern und den tarif
insgesamt anpassen damit wird diese
leistungsfeindliche politik so nicht
bekommen und alle steuerzahler wirklich
entlasten liebe kolleginnen
die werke die ich freue mich auf die
gespräche im finanzausschuss da brauchen
sie jetzt nicht zu schweigen sondern wir
sollten eine sachliche diskussion führen
über die frage wer bei den gesetzentwurf
gestalten sie haben ja an anderer stelle
und auch dass es angesprochen worden
weitere vorschläge gemacht zur
steuerlichen maßnahmen zu
entlastungsmaßnahmen
das halte ich auch für richtig dass wir
die frage diskutieren und ich bin der
meinung sie würden gut daran tun wenn
sie sich daran erinnern dass wir heute
in der ersten lesung sind und dass sie
jetzt als koalition nicht einfach
hingehen und sagen das hat die regierung
vorgelegten das ziehen wir jetzt 1 1
durch die lage hat sich geändert ich
habe es bei der inflation angesprochen
aber dieser gesetzentwurf ist auch
entstanden bevor der angriffskrieg auf
die ukrainerin hat und frau sie haben ja
richtig teil ihrer einschätzung zur
allgemeinen wirtschaftlichen lage es
besteht die gefahr mehr
bundesfinanzminister als auch
entsprochen dass wir jetzt in der
situation in eine stagnation
hineinlaufen und wenn wir das gemeinsam
so sehen sie aus der regierung seite und
wir aus der opposition dann dürfen wir
nicht warten bis wir in der stadt
station sind sondern wir müssen jetzt
maßnahmen ergreifen dass wir nicht
hineinkommen und deshalb ist es
notwendig bezogen auf inflation bei den
bürgern zu entlasten
es ist aber auch notwendig bezogen auf
die wirtschaft dass wir maßnahmen
ergreifen das wird zusätzliches
wirtschaftliches wachstum generieren und
dazu haben wir in unserem antrag sehr
wohl vorschläge unterbreitet ich nenne
das thema verlust drückt sowohl die
frage der höhe wie auch die frage wie
lange man zurück tragen kann haben wir
angesprochen das ist eine maßnahme
sie haben selbst im koalitionsvertrag
ihrer turbo abschreibung wo bleiben ihre
turbo abschreibungen wir verlangen dass
sie haben dem koalitionsvertrag machen
wir es doch gemeinsam nichts ist von
ihnen zu hören sie schauen bedroht
betreten unter sich jetzt wäre die zeit
das anzupacken und der wirtschaftlichen
signal zu geben liebe kolleginnen und
und ich will an der stelle noch ein
weiterer hinweis geben wo ich auch
dringend handlungsbedarf sehe der
bundesfinanzminister ist nicht
verantwortlich für die geldpolitik das
hier war glaube ich uns alle einig
geldpolitik wird von der notenbank
gemacht aber die bundesregierung hat aus
meiner sicht eine verantwortung in der
finanzpolitik der geldpolitik den
notwendigen spielraum zu schaffen damit
man eine vernünftige geldpolitik machen
kann bisher erfüllt sich doch die
notenbank eingeschränkt durch die hohen
schulden die wir in deutschland rona
bedingt und in europa haben und deshalb
glaubt die noten maxi kann
möglicherweise das gar nicht tun was
notwendig wäre in der jetzigen situation
und deshalb fordere ich sie auf jenseits
der steuerpolitik schaffen sie in der
haushaltspolitik die voraussetzungen
dass die notenbank das tun kann was
notwendig ist um inflation in diesem
land zu bekämpfen inflation ist die
sozialste politik die es gibt und die
dürfen wir in deutschland nicht zulassen
und ich will in den letzten über merkel
machen zum thema home office pauschale
ich finde es gut dass wir die haben die
es entstanden in der pandemie aber ich
glaube wir müssen doch zur kenntnis
nehmen auch wenn jetzt was in der
pandemie entstanden ist ist das thema
home office mobiles arbeiten eine
grundsätzliche veränderung der
arbeitswelt und deshalb rege ich an dass
wir in der beratung mal darüber
nachdenken ob er das von der pandemie
bekämpfung lösen und nicht als
dauereinrichtung schaffen um uns den
veränderungen der arbeitswelt auch in
der steuerpolitik anzupassen und in dem
sinne lade ich sie zu guten gesprächen
ein ich würde mich freuen wenn das
gelingt bei uns haben so oft eine
ansprechpartner ob das lieber kollege
müller auch innerhalb der koalition
gelingt bin ich skeptisch nachdem
kollegen kaspar zugehört und eben und
habe ich größere differenzen raus gehört
als zu uns vielen dank und gute beratung
nächster redner für die spd fraktion
bernhard daldrup
[Applaus]
ok
wusste gar nicht dass es war ein weiter
so hoch geht hier also
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen frau
präsidentin liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen es ist jetzt von mehreren
betont worden die aktuelle
krisensituation sie fordert
entschlossenes handeln das ist glaube
ich auch hinreichend dokumentiert bei
den kostensteigerungen für strom
lebensmittel heizung mobilität und bei
der noch mal verschärft angespannten
lage auf den energiemärkten erst recht
und das durchaus auch bei einer
jedenfalls vermeintlich anhaltenden
inflation ich habe dir da die
darstellung des finanzministers hier
überhaupt nicht zu relativieren und zu
kritisieren die war schon so zutreffend
die kosten sind eben ganz
unterschiedlich spürbar an der zapfsäule
bei der miete bei den unternehmen auch
und darauf müssen wir ganz zielgerichtet
reagieren und das machen wir auch heute
jetzt gerade durch diese
steuerentlastungsgesetz wir reden heute
noch über das vierte corona steuer hilfe
gesetz aber eben auch mit anderen
maßnahmen ich will an dieser stelle mal
sagen die der regierungskoalition hat
relativ schnell gehandelt und die
maßnahmenpakete die zur entlastung
dienen macht ein volumen von deutlich
mehr als 30 milliarden euro aus das muss
man schlicht und ergreifend noch mal
wiederholen und deutlich sagen um den
menschen klarzumachen ja wir helfen
tatsächlich mit den vorliegenden
steuerentlastungsgesetz setzen wir ja
maßnahmen aus dem ersten
entlastungspaket um dann sage ich mal
ist jetzt hier angesprochen wurden
erhebung der arbeitnehmer pauschbetrages
von 200 euro auf 1200 euro rückwirkend
und dann ist gesagt worden vom
bundesfinanzminister das ist in den
letzten elf jahren nicht passiert und es
gab raunen bei der cdu und ich sage mal
so ich empfinde das überhaupt nicht als
einen vorwurf wenn es jetzt die spd und
die fdp und die grünen gemeinsam machen
wenn ihr das kritisiert müsste
eigentlich sozusagen merken dass die
finger auf euch selber zeigen das finde
ich jedenfalls an dieser stelle
und freibetrag ist dieselbe sache fritz
güntzler hat gesagt von neun
1984 auf 10.300 47 kommt überwiegend den
geringeren einkommen zugute ich weiß
jetzt nicht ob er das begrüßt oder nicht
ich hab es jedenfalls begrüßt ich find's
ganz in ordnung und der meister sagt das
wäre irgendwie leistungsfeindlich was
man sonst nicht macht der meister wissen
sie was leistungsfeindlich ist
leistungsfeindlich ist es wenn man
leistungslose vermögen nicht hinreichend
besteuert das ist leistungsfeindlich
danken sie uns in eine bredouille
bringen aber dann haben sie sich erst
mal selber in eine bredouille bringen
befristete anhebung entfernungspauschale
für fernpendler
da will ich aber sagen kollegen wird
muss man darauf hinweisen dass auch die
mobilitäts prämie für geringverdiener
wächst von 20 bis zu 120 euro ist auch
ein gesichtspunkt in paris keine
zwischenfragen mehr entschuldigung aber
irgendwann auch derzeit bin ja eder
netzte wir berichten heute auch über
weitere steuerliche erleichterungen
viertes coroner steuer hilfe gesetzt
habe ich eben gesagt die verlängerung
der degressiven abschreibung ist eine
massive entlastung und die ist eine
entlastung an der übrigens länder und
kommunen zu zwei dritteln mit beteiligt
sind und ist ein ganz wichtiger schritt
denn sollten sie begrüßen und die
verlängerung der home office pauschale
sozusagen dauerhaft das hätte die auch
in der regierung niemals gemacht haben
wir auch darüber gesprochen also
insofern sollte erinnert euch erinnert
euch einfach mal ich hab die vorschläge
der union gesehen und ich weiß ich kenne
ja die akteure und schätze die ja auch
persönlich sie sind so ein bisschen die
sind immer so ein bisschen im rausch der
steuerberatenden berufe sozusagen und
abgeordneten das verstehe ich schon das
verstehe ich schon durchaus aber ich
sage mal nur entlastung für große
vermögen die jetzt nicht wirklich auf
die aktuelle situation
reagieren sind unzureichend ich sag das
noch mal wenn ihr uns wirklich sozusagen
als ampel in eine schwierigkeit bringen
wollte dann würde dir die frage mit
vorschlägen verbinden wie denn sozusagen
die finanzierung all der großen ausgaben
auch durch beteiligung großer und
größter vermögen vielleicht gelingen
könnte aber das machen sie gar nicht was
sie das ja auch gar nicht wollen und
deswegen sage ich mal an dieser stelle
ist das was wir tun der richtige der
richtige weg die unbefristete vertrag
schon angesprochen unsere steuerlichen
maßnahmen entlasten bürgerinnen und
bürger und unternehmen wird sein und
gezielt aber es sind eben auch noch
andere entlastungsmaßnahmen außerhalb
des steuerrechtes die eeg-umlage
beispielsweise bei einer dreiköpfigen
familie 133 euro der heizkostenzuschuss
für wohngeldempfänger
den führen wir ein es wird über
gutachten festgestellt 133 euro sonst
seien dann verdoppeln wir dass die
linken sagen freundlicherweise ihr macht
ja mehr als wir gefordert haben wir
schließen uns an und die union sagt mich
genug
und jetzt bei der entfernungspauschale
sind bastian bremen haben sich eben
gehört der kollege der linken sagt jetzt
unter überholen die uns schon wieder
links also ich sag mal leute überlegt
euch das mal was fordert und was das mit
der glaubwürdigkeit eigentlich zu tun
eure eigenen arbeit
ich will die anderen sachen für soziale
ausgewogenheit kurz mal eben auch sagen
die einmalzahlungen für menschen die
arbeitslosengeld 2 oder grundsicherung
beziehen zweimal die sofort zuschlag für
bedürftige kinder bis wir endlich so
kindergrundsicherung kommen die wir ja
auch verabredet haben wir werden
voraussichtlich noch ein paar weitere
maßnahmen aufnehmen ich sagte dass ein
dort ausdrücklich auch die die
energiepreis pauschale von 300 euro für
einkommen steuerpflichtige erwerbstätige
um selbstständige die wird besteuert ja
ist sowie ein höheres einkommen hat
weniger entlastungen dadurch ist so dass
nennt nun soziale gerechtigkeit an einer
solchen kleinen stelle was ist daran
schlecht überhaupt nicht finde ich
jedenfalls und
ich sag mal die absenkung der energie
steuern auf kraftstoffe auf das
europäische mindestens drei monate lang
30 cent weniger für benzin 14 cent
weniger für diese auch glaube ich
vernünftig aber wichtig ist auch über
kartell und wettbewerbsrechtliche
maßnahmen sicherzustellen dass die
absenkung der energiesteuern und
sinkende rohstoff rohstoffpreise auch
tatsächlich bei den verbraucherinnen und
verbrauchern ankommen ich sag mal die
pnv pauschale 3 x 3 x 9 euro ist auch
eine entlastung gesagt dass deshalb auch
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen weil es
falsch ist wenn wir in der jetzigen
situation darauf achten welche gruppe
ist denn eigentlich am meisten und am
wenigsten betroffen wir hätten rinnen
und rentner haben an vielen stellen von
diesen geschichten auch etwas der
heizkostenzuschuss 48 prozent sind
rentnerinnen und rentner aber viel zu
wenig rentnerinnen und rentner
beantragen wollen wird das müssten sie
eigentlich machen das wäre sehr viel
vernünftiger ich weiß nicht warum leider
leider muss ich zum schluss kommen aber
ich will noch einmal einen punkt sagen
in anknüpfung an das was wieso braucht
auch gesagt ja es geht ja nicht nur um
diese einzelnen schnellen hilfsmaßnahmen
dazu seien bereits ab punkt sein
schon fast am ende es geht auch um
strukturelle maßnahmen zu einer höheren
resilienz und zu einer höheren fähigkeit
für die transformation die jetzt in
unser paket beschlossen werden darüber
werden wir die gelegenheit dar um die
nächste dazu diskutieren herzlichen dank
sagte pörner druck
für die spd fraktion im finanzausschuss
sitzt oder der letzte gewesen ist in
dieser debatte in dieser ersten beratung
des steuerentlastungsgesetzes
20 22 das wird jetzt weiter beraten im
finanzausschuss genauso wie einen antrag
der unionsfraktion mit dem titel mut zu
wesentlichen steuerlichen hilfsmaßnahmen
auch das wie gesagt erst mal im
finanzausschuss und dann in kürze wieder
in zweiter und dritter beratung hier im
plenum des deutschen bundestags